los números finales no se conocerán
hasta dentro de unos días o incluso
semanas pero para la casa blanca el
hecho de que los republicanos no vayan
arrasado ni en la cámara de
representantes ni en el senado fue una
reivindicación en sí misma los
demócratas tuvieron una noche fuerte y
perdimos menos escaños en la cámara de
representantes que en cualquier elección
de mitad de mandato de los demócratas en
los últimos 40 años la votación del
martes sí rompió con el mall de
histórico de las elecciones de mitad de
mandato en las que el partido del
presidente suele sufrir profundas
pérdidas pero aunque no hubiera una ola
roja republicana el control de ambas
cámaras sigue en juego la cámara de
representantes podría seguir siendo
controlada Por los republicanos con un
margen menor del esperado batallas clave
en el oeste concretamente en California
Siguen sin ser confirmadas los
republicanos quieren llegar a 218
escaños para el control y si lo
consiguen eso podría frenar la agenda
legislativa de biden en cuanto al senado
el control depende de los tres estados
que los resultados aún confirmados
Nevada Arizona y Georgia cualquiera de
los partidos necesita ganar al menos dos
de los tres para controlar la cámara
alta en Nevada se siguen recibiendo los
votos por correo marcados el día
siguiente de las elecciones los
funcionarios electorales advierten que
el recuento en Las Vegas y reno podría
tardar días tenemos
14.718 votos por correo que no fueron
leídos anoche y que entrarán hoy la
recogida del usps para hoy fue de más de
12.700 papeletas en Arizona la carrera
sigue siendo demasiado reñida y un fallo
de impresión retrasó el recuento y luego
está Georgia donde Ninguno de los
candidatos recibió más del 50%, Así que
se celebrará una segunda vuelta el 6 de
diciembre si Nevada fuera para los
republicanos y Arizona para los
demócratas o viceversa Georgia podría
como lo hizo en el anterior senado
dictar Qué partido controla la cámara
alta